[Music]
my name is Richard I work in London with
the Google Play consulting and I'm here
today to talk to you about pre-launch
report and I am Justin tech lead manager
for the firebase test lab thank you the
brave few have made it at this rather
ungodly hour the night after the party
and I'm sure that that scary rather
wordy title didn't help did we really
use the word autonomous Marketing
insisted so if you're here for in wham-o
talk you're in the wrong place today
we're here to talk to you about
intelligent app and game testing that
requires mercifully little work on your
part it's available on both the Play
console and in firebase test lab both
products have massively increased their
offering and we're here to tell you
about what's in one what's in the other
and what's in both and we'll tell you
our story in the context of an app
testing is a pain but as you've probably
heard multiple times this week it's
really important so as much as possible
we want to take Google's expertise and
resources and make it our pain and not
yours so let's start by talking about
the pre-launch report this is an
automated scan of your app that aims to
give you an early warning of quality
problems before your users see them it's
a free service and it applies
automatically to every apk publish two
plays alpha or beta tracks or as you may
have heared this week the new open and
closed testing tracks we take apks that
you pass to Google Play and we install
them onto about 10 devices these devices
span a range there are high end devices
like the pixel 2 and down to low end
devices like the Samsung Galaxy j1
once we have the apk installed on the
device we start a special Robo crawler
process the Robo crawler explores your
album and putting taps and swipes and
texts as a user would this takes place
on physical infrastructure which is part
of a larger farm with thousands of
different devices and a large diversity
of hardware and operating systems your
fellow developers have told us that they
take pre-launch report very seriously in
a recent survey 86 percent said that
they consider pre-launch report results
to be important or very important when
they're considering whether it's time to
launch a new amp into production when
developers have ignored our
recommendation and launched in something
that we found problems our data says
that about 75% of the time the problems
that we found in pre-launch report were
later seen by real users those users got
a poor experience they may have left bad
reviews they may have left bad ratings
they may have chose not to spend money
in the app and they may even have
uninstalled the app furthermore
pre-launch report test results are used
internally within play as one of a
number of factors when deciding how to
feature and rank apps in the Play Store
as of today we've called over a million
different apps and if we're not already
crawling yours we'd really like to be
doing that now as you've probably
guessed from why I've said pre-launch
report is pretty good at finding crashes
when we find the crash in your app while
we test it we give you a lot of
information stack traces log cats things
like that everything you need to debug
the crash and fix it but we don't just
do crashes we also take screenshots and
capture a video of the crawl on each
device so that you can look for UX
issues in different languages in October
we added performance data
this is Network memory and CPU metrics
so that you can look for performance
issues in your app so that's what my
team does the play pre-launch report
what about your team Justin so my team
works on firebase test lab so firebase
test lab is a separate
Ellucian that is part of the suite of
products under the firebase umbrella it
uses the same technology as the
pre-launch report including the larger
device form that Richard mentioned it
offers many of the same features but it
also integrates with a number of
different tools such as Android studio
Fastlane G cloud SDK and of course the
firebase console allowing developers to
test their apps and games at all stages
of the application lifecycle across a
wider array of devices giving you more
comprehensive test results so let's talk
about an app this is Fitness bud now
while Fitness bud is not a real
application it does illustrate
real-world problems problems we know you
all have Fitness but is a social fitness
tracking application built by let's say
a small company FB solutions fitness bud
allows you to log in with a Google
account or a custom account create an
online fitness avatar invite fitness
buddies with whom to train and even join
a local gym Richard and I are gonna take
you through how FB solutions makes use
of the many new tools at their disposal
to develop test and release they're soon
to be wildly successful application
thanks Justin now as my wife likes to
remind me what I'm being smug about
something my body shape is best
described as a potato on legs so I
really need Fitness but to be very very
good I need all the help I can get
so how many of you have spouses like no
sorry how many of you have way more time
than you know what to do with and can
fix every last problem in your app
nobody yeah neither do we
with all of the signals that pre-launch
report makes available to you we know it
can be hard to prioritize to decide
which of these issues is the most urgent
that you should fix so starting this
week we've launched a new page which
digests all of the issues we found into
a single launch recommendation as you
can see here this shows up at the top of
a new overview tab the overview tab then
displays all of the issues that
pre-launch report has found prioritized
by severity this new tab makes it easy
for fitness bird to see at a glance if
this new apk that they have is a release
candidate is ready to be released to
users or not now test labs intelligent
crawler does a great job of crawling the
android framework part of fitness bud
but Fitness bud uses OpenGL for a an
online fitness avatar creation part
previously the pre-launch report
couldn't test apps and games which used
OpenGL but now it can if you're a game
developer you can write what are called
demo loops demo loops are an automated
journey through your app they can focus
on a particular level or a particular
game character demo loops are a great
way they they are an intent filter but
is declared in your manifest they're not
normally called as part of your rule the
normal running of your application but
our test infrastructure will detect them
and run them demo loops launched last
year in firebase test lab and starting
this week demo loops are now available
in pre-launch report as well so if you
choose to add a demo loop to your app
when we take your app through pre-launch
report rather than the usual Robo
crawler we will run the demo loop and
then output the full set of pre logical
output will look for crashes and most
importantly will give you those
performance traces so you can use demo
loops for accurate benchmarking on our
range of devices if you don't use the
demo loop we will use another new
feature called
reactions when we detect that the
crawler has discovered an OpenGL part of
your app will fall back to random input
so we get at least some crawling for you
fitness but really cares about keeping
its users data safe and secure so
Fitness bread requires custom login or
login with Google and if you use
firebase off both of these are supported
as I was saying before I was so rudely
interrupted by that message from our
sponsors free launch report uses an auto
log-in feature as we test your app or as
we test Fitness Birds app when we see a
sign-in with Google button we will use
it and we automatically have a Google
account on the device ready to be signed
in at the patients that don't use log in
with Google can choose to configure
pre-launch report with a username or an
email address and a password that we
will again use to get past the login
screen when we see it next let's talk
about deep links deep links are a way
for users to invoke functionality within
your app that bypasses the normal entry
flow for example a user might start off
searching the web but should be shown
those search results within your app so
how many of you have deep links in your
apps Wow
yeah how many of you test those deep
links at every release of the app
solution so fitness but have this
problem they use deep links to encourage
users to sign up to local gyms the user
receives a firebase notification
alerting them to a special offer they
click the link in the notification and
they're taken straight to firebases
the gym signups go back to Fitness Birds
Gym signup screen this is a very
important flow for them because money
changes hands launching this week
pre-launch report will now test up to
three deep links you can configure it
and add the deep links we crawl as usual
for the five minutes then at the end of
the crawl we close the app and visit
each deep link in turn as we virtually
visit each deep link we crawl for a
further 30 seconds so Fitness bud and
you can make sure that
users who follow deep links can have the
same great experience so as we have seen
from the million glass apps that the
crawler has tested sometimes crucial
parts of an application are only reached
through some complicated flow like
fitness buds gym signup form it turns
out that automated crawlers and even
some humans not that good at entering
the correct text to bypass this form so
this is where Robo scripts come in these
are another new feature robust kurtz
provide guidance to our crawler to get
past a complicated part of the app they
take the form of a short scripted
sequences of actions recorded as a JSON
file you can record robot scripts using
a tool built into Android studio with
the app running locally you record a
series of taps and swipes you then
upload this script to pre-launch report
or to firebase test lab the Robo script
guides the early part of the crawl
carrying out the pre-recorded sequences
to get the app into some state that you
think will be interesting to test once
it's completed the Robo script it starts
crawling normally now robot scripts are
not only useful for crawling forms they
can also be used to guide the crawler
past any parts that it finds tricky to
navigate usability and accessibility are
really important to your app if you make
your touch targets too small you might
have a result like this not not one of
your better days at the gym Justin does
that happen to you a lot actually no but
I do seem to have a rather persistent
irrational fear of treadmills and
haven't been on one since I think that's
probably wise in the next few weeks
we're gonna add to pre-launch report an
intelligent crawler that's going to help
uncover usability issues like that tiny
button that poor Justin was trying so
hard to click there all jokes aside Oh
small touch targets are a problem for a
wide range of users
including users using your app on the go
one-handed or users with dexterity
impairments legible text is also
exclusive extremely important so we will
warn you when text is too small or we
will warn you when the contrast is too
low
some visually impaired users rely
heavily on talkback so we will also tell
you when talkback voiceover annotations
are missing or confusing as you can tell
that infamous button I was trying so
hard to click is included in the
usability remote results and it's got a
big red box around it and thankfully as
far as I'm concerned its marked as
should fix so after a full sprint of bug
fixing fitna spread up loads of fresh
apk to the Google Play console and they
take another look at the pre-launch
reports overview tab as you can see here
there are no longer any serious issues
detected they can now push this apk into
their production Channel confident that
their users will be receiving a good
experience so we hope that you too can
adopt the pre-launch report as part of
your decision to launch so that's where
you get in pre-launch report which is
available for free to everyone who
publishes apks to what we used to call
the alpha or beta channels but now call
open and closed testing tracks you can
find it in the Google Play console under
manage releases thank you Richard so as
developers we know that the earlier we
catch problems the easier they are to
fix so if you're a conscientious
developer or you just like saving money
you want to catch problems as quickly as
possible this is where firebase test lab
comes in now many of us myself included
have discussed ad nauseam about the
importance of creating automated tests
for every part of your application and
to run those tests continuously to
prevent regressions
this is honestly the most important
thing you can do to improve the quality
of your applications but writing tests
is hard that's why when I ask in
gatherings like this how many of you
have automated tests that cover every
part of your application way too few of
you put up your hands so I gave up
nagging a while ago
and we at Google have put a lot of focus
into creating write creating tests for
apps and games without actually having
to write those tests earlier we saw the
automated crawler which is part of
firebase test lab as what we call a robo
test but we can do much more let's look
at how we can create tests for all the
different parts of fitness bug so one of
the first things that I as a user of
fitness bud will want to do is create my
fitness avatar which involves uploading
my photo and from that photo there it is
I the app actually creates a caricature
of me which seems to have emphasized all
my worst floor worst flaws it then
allows me to choose a focused activity
weight training and is that really you
up there just what appears that my ears
are not my worst floor vanity is then I
get to guide my excessively buffed
avatar around the various gym activities
with all my equally unrealistic fitness
buddies now all this avatar stuff is
written in OpenGL for a more immersive
and fun experience for the user and
previously it's been hard to test
apps and games which use OpenGL but over
the last year
weird Google have introduced a couple of
ways in which you can now do this more
easily so we introduced at i/o last year
the concept of demo loops that Justin
and I discussed earlier and prelaunch
Report now runs demo loops in your apps
and games if you choose to include them
now fitness bud can construct demo loops
for all this avatar stuff by simply
recording and replaying their OpenGL
commands and then during testing they
can verify that they don't see crashes
or performance issues now Fitness pod
can run these demo loops locally on
their devices using an app that we
created that's freely available but more
importantly they can run those demo
loops in firebase test lab across a wide
array of devices secondly we announced
at the games developer conference
earlier on this year a collaboration
with net E's to create tests for games
that run in firebase test lab net YZ is
one of the largest games development
companies in China and as part of this
collaboration they open sourced their
test environments air tests along with a
couple of frameworks that they use
internally for developing tests for
their own games now you can download
this testing framework there is a link
at the end and with it you can create
tests that add actions and assertions
that refer to game elements so let's see
how that works so here's their test and
I'm just going to select game elements
and add an action to touch a game
element I can wait for a game element to
exist
or I can assert that of the game element
is visible it's that simple
like demo loops these tests can be run
locally but they can also be run in fire
based test lab across a wide array of
devices now here's the goal creation
screen the fitness bud now my fitness
goals are pretty modest as you saw
earlier it's a good day if I don't fall
off a treadmill with this screen users
get to create fitness goals and share
them with all their fitness buddies
now obviously Fitness bud wants to
create tests that cover this part of the
app as well now typically this involves
laborious lis writing tests in one of
the many testing frameworks such as
espresso or UI Automator and then
keeping those tests updated as the UI
evolves so I don't know actually
let me quickly ask how many of you have
had to rewrite dozens or even hundreds
of UI tests because you've made some
small change in your app right and it's
really painful right it's just happened
to me too I know exactly this is a this
is a really painful situation so this is
the exact reason why we built espresso
test recorder espresso test recorder is
part of Android studio and with it you
can quickly record espresso tests by
simply interacting with your device
running your app locally with it we can
create lots of tests that cover the non
OpenGL parts of fitness bud now you can
create these tests in either Java or
Kotlin but the best thing is that if
your UI does change you can go back in
and easily rerecord those tests
let's see how this works all right this
is Android studio here I'm going to
choose to record an espresso test I'm
gonna pick my local pixel 2 which is
running then compiles and installs my
app and brings up this event window and
this point I get to enter my name click
on an avatar and it records the events
all there in that window next I want to
add an assertion so adding an assertion
involves pulling a screenshot from the
device so that I can select elements in
that screenshot on which I want to
assert I will do that click on an
element and then I'm gonna click OK I
get to choose Java or Kotlin I'm gonna
choose Cortland I'm gonna click OK and
there is my Coughlin test class it's
that simple with the espresso test
recorder you can modularize your testing
you can create test snippets for the
commonly used functions in all your
tests such as logging in or filling out
a search form and so with all that free
time all those excuses for not going to
the gym simply evaporate so now Fitness
pod has a battery of tests and all they
have to do is add them to their
continuous integration system and now
every time they make a change they can
be much more confident this is the
beauty much more confident that it did
not break the app in some obscure way
and I mean speaking as a developer
myself peace of mind like that is
honestly priceless
but Fitness bird is going to have to run
on the myriad of devices that people
drag to the gym how do they make sure
that the app runs well on all those
devices well they could buy a whole
bunch of devices hook them up to a
workstation and stick them in a closet
somewhere
but Fitness buds cheaper closets are
full of gym bags because they practice
what they preach Plus maintaining a
device closet is a really hard and
soul-destroying activity trust me on
this not only do you have to keep the
devices online and updated but you also
have to procure new ones as the old ones
die or explode and fresh ones come out
onto the market Fitness bud would much
rather be cutting code or pumping iron
so what's the alternative so Justin and
I have already described to you how pill
ontraport offers free krawler testing on
about ten devices so every APK that
Fitness bird upload but you can go much
further with the fire-based test lab
using a broader range of devices
covering an even wider gamut of screen
sizes Android API versions different
OEMs and different chipsets and so to
illustrate this we recently added
pre-release P devices that you can now
all test on but what I'm most excited
today to announce wait for it is our new
support for iOS I already was already up
there all right you already knew so you
can sign up for a beta through the
firebase console there's a link at the
end
quiet fitness buddy is a global
application and as such it needs to be
tested on a whole bunch of different
languages both fire based test lab and
the play console
allow you to do just that with firebase
coder with firebase test lab you can run
your tests on any look all you wish and
pre-launch report recommends the most
popular languages amongst your users so
now there should be no reason for
fitness bud to waste all that time and
energy maintaining a device closet which
gives them even more time to spend at
the gym it's kind of a wonder they get
any coding down action like in the
pre-launch report fire based test lab
also gives you comprehensive test
results like crashes and ANR's
video and screenshots logs performance
metrics a map of the activities the
crawler found the video and screenshots
are especially important to help fitness
bud
verify that their app looks good and
runs well across all those screen sizes
and orientations and locales let's look
at how easy it is to quickly run a test
in the firebase console firstly I want
to quickly point out on you iOS support
there it is you dismiss that coach mark
but it's there we're gonna run a robo
test Robo test is the simplest of tests
all it requires as you is you that you
give us your app now I'm gonna quickly
choose an app at random from my hard
disk there and upload it while it's
uploading you'll note we can also upload
a robo script which we're not going to
do here but now I get to choose my
devices
from amongst the many devices some of
these devices are deprecated which means
they exploded and we can no longer
procure them I'm going to go with the
default two devices but I do want to add
some locals I'm going to add Chinese I'm
going to add Arabic when I get there and
then lastly I'm going to add Spanish and
then I'm gonna fix the locales cuz I
really only care about portrait mode and
then fix little girls please there we go
then I'm gonna start eight Tests eight
Tests because it's two devices times for
locales so now what test lab is gonna do
is in the background it will allocate
eight devices it will configure those
devices setting the locale the
orientation it will then install my app
on all those devices and then it will
run a five minute robo test which will
take five minutes so oh thank god it's
done alright there we go I'm gonna pick
the first of these you see we have logs
we have screenshots we have an activity
map which is a map of the activity to be
visited you have performance information
which is tied to the video so you can
see what's happening in your app at the
time of the CPU spikes or or the a
frames per second drops
you can find instructions on the web on
the fire based documentation site for
how to hook test lab up to many common
continuous integration systems like
Jenkins or circle CI or team city we
have a number of customers who are doing
exactly this testing their app multiple
times a day test lab is helping them
find problems way before they end up
affecting their users and best of all
you can get started for free with our
spark billing tier so it's really that
simple
Justin I hope that our talk here today
can give you a renewed inspiration for
your testing strategy it doesn't have to
be difficult to test comprehensively let
the pre pre-launch report in the Google
Play console help you discover crashes
performance issues security
vulnerabilities and soon accessibility
warnings with zero configuration
required from you just publish an apk to
the open or closed testing tracks and a
report will be generated for you you can
go further than the auto-generated
report by giving us custom login
credentials Robo scripts deep links and
demo loops to help us test your app
better and if you want to test maybe
more often maybe more comprehensively
take a look at firebase test lab which
in addition to the features Richard just
mentioned also allows you to create and
run your own tests so take a picture of
this if you wish give you a couple of
seconds to do that I think those people
have already done that we'd really love
to hear more from you so if you have any
comments or suggestions please use the
link in the i/o app or come find us in
person after the talk thank you very
much thanks
[Applause]
[Music]